[Music]
yeah man so
everyone's a cold case
detective now all of tick-tock is
detectives
rest in peace to gabby potito man yeah
i couldn't like you know there's a
podcast for it
no way someone started a podcast for it
already i thought that was kind of it's
like weird like these people on tick
tock their entire
like audience
was created just because of this case
yeah they were like following it so
closely yeah i don't know it's like i
don't know let the police do their thing
no but then there's the other part of it
where the they possibly would not have
found her body that's true yeah that is
true
so it is true you can't be
i just think starting a podcast is weird
because you know you're trying to read
ads well that's the thing on tick tock
too it's like people are making money
from their videos
yeah i guess but i think it's also some
people that just like
are passionate about investigative
stuff definitely
i mean the the bottom line though is
if there wasn't all this uh
talk about it those you know those
travel vloggers who posted that clip
yeah they may never have
they might they might have did that in
like three years yep it is pretty wild
how that actually worked out you know i
feel like that stuff like that's the
thing about these
like tick-tock accounts and stuff is
that people are like i can't believe the
police haven't figured out yet that this
observation is like they probably have
it's just they're building a case so you
can't yeah they can't just like say that
say that because it'll ruin their whole
case
so
like you know they're not going to be on
tick tock talking about like the
observations they're making stuff like
that yeah and people just
you know make these crazy like you know
there's so many stories in the past of
like the wrong person being targeted
because someone
on social media was like this is the guy
yeah and then the light guy's life is
ruined and yep and so like
i'm just floored by the fact that that
actually was the van because like a lot
of the comments were like this is
probably not it like it is coincidental
but most things are and then that's
where her body was found i i read about
the the
the lesbian couple that was shot yeah
apparently the connection was ruled out
on that
yeah it was again like this is just me
falling for this stuff
but this is pretty crazy like it was in
the same area
like a couple days
before her disappearance right yeah they
were found
they were found dead i think
some days
after
they had been seen so it's just like uh
but i guess their friends had
you know
said that this couple had described a
uh like a weird man outside of their
home or something her boyfriend
gabby's is now gone brian landry yeah
that he's on the run
so he definitely did it
he he did that and probably some more
you know who knows i mean the the theory
is that he
you know has murdered multiple people
that's what a lot of people are saying
which
that's
who knows like we'll have to have to see
but
i didn't spend too much time but i guess
you know the loose connections people
are making is
there's like claimed sightings of him
and then coincidentally people are found
dead but
you know either way apparently 710
indigenous people went missing in
wyoming in the past year or something
really yeah people are sort of saying
like it's it's
shitty that a youtuber got all this
attention but i think the the positive
here is that now it is like putting a
light on i think it's yellowstone i
don't know where it was whatever
national park she went to i guess it's a
common occurrence that in this national
park that people just go missing
wyoming national park
i don't why'd i say yellowstone i don't
know it's just nuts that the internet
sort of got it right yeah yep
because with the you know boston bomber
situation read it [ __ ] that up that's
the one i was talking royally that's
what i was talking about some somebody
got targeted unfairly right because they
were like this is the guy it was a kid
that had had been missing it was like a
family who lost their son who had gone
missing i think i have that right and
reddit for some reason got the kids
mixed up and then
all these people are posting and talking
about
you know this kid who had been missing
and the family just goes through all
this trauma because the internet is like
your [ __ ] son
did the boston bombing they're like what
our kids been gone like yeah and
there's something to the tune of that
but the bottom line is reddit had gotten
that wrong to the point that you know
now
forever they're always
having to moderate posts and [ __ ]
because they're like remember when we
[ __ ] it up yeah
so do you see the random picture of the
bald guy walking no and a lot of people
think that it's him yeah is he is he
like barefoot yes yeah yes
that's like that's the type of picture
like that that's what i'm talking about
yeah that's some dude living in that
neighborhood yeah it just looks like
that guy yeah just barefoot and bald
yeah he's like he's like 40 years old
yeah
well i've i haven't had a i haven't had
a girlfriend yeah
yeah
yeah bro between that and the doc i
watched about that woman in cork yeah
that picture right there
had brian laundry been spotted neighbors
claimed to take a pic of gabby potatoes
bow
bow i mean that code is walking outside
his home so yeah okay maybe that makes
more sense
that's the thing about
certain
certain serial killers man they got
the stupidest confidence yeah why is it
that they want to get caught well i
guess like they want to become martyrs
or whatever like they like the attention
which is sick but i only
can hope that
like anyone else that they get this dude
because he needs to admit bro if he goes
and you know kills himself in the woods
he [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
he deserves to suffer sorry that got
weirdly dark
yeah
the same man now it's true though it is
true
anyways speaking of depressing things
um
let's talk about bitcoin i'm like
looking for something that's not
depressing on here
it was a hell of a weekend man
oh i'll tell you oh oh [ __ ]
um evergrand what about them
they're like the second biggest
uh real estate developer in china
and uh yesterday
they defaulted on 300 billion dollars of
loans so this is like
you know the the size that could have
economic repercussions around the world
if they go under so they like have been
over leveraged for like years like it's
kind of a ponzi scheme a little bit they
build buildings right like the chinese
housing market in like
2018-19 was like insane and so they were
building all these super build all these
buildings super fast they're borrowing
money to do it and they'd sell the
buildings use that money borrow some
more money to do new buildings yeah so
they're kind of always borrowing money
super over leveraged yeah borrowing way
too much yeah overexposed like crazy
didn't vice also do a bunch of segments
on these like
chinese superstructures
that were like
large housing complexes with no one in
them yes so i think that was also them
okay but that was a while ago yeah i
think like ghost cities yeah yeah
something about evergreen where they
like poured more concrete than the
entire world in a certain year i forget
what year it was and all these ghost
cities because something you know the
market crash or something like that yeah
um
which essentially is what's happening
now a little bit the market has kind of
i think tanked a little bit because they
impose all these rules anyways
now all of a sudden people aren't buying
the buildings and so they're about to
default on 300 billion dollars they were
so in debt that they asked all of their
own employees to lend them money and if
they didn't they would lose their bonus
for the year so their own employees were
going to their families getting them to
invest money in their own company and it
was a loan so they were supposed to be
paid interest on it
and now all of a sudden the government
was like warning people like hey
evergrand
i don't think they're going to be
able to pay their interest two percent
of china's gdp that is insane
yep oh yeah i remember
when those vice segments about the ghost
cities they would say you know this is
all just to
represent
an increase in gdp
for china and it
it's like for what it's for nothing
yep damn those buildings are crazy
economic meltdown that's what we need
way to make it positive dude yeah yeah
i mean it's just really interesting no
it's super interesting